moi les champs les donneurs de leçons
sur les réseaux sociaux qui dès qu'un
truc et viennent se mêler et viennent
enfoncer alors que tu as déjà une
polémique de fou ça c'est insupportable
eric bon d'accord j'en ai marre mme
nabila parce que moi j'en ai fait un peu
kim kardashian version de discount c'est
à dire que là pas de shampooing faut que
ton la personne allez-y non mais on lui
offre un sac il faut que la terre
entière le ici ensuite regardé les
vivait avec 25
il est question de toutes ces épreuves
surmontées je me battrai toute ma vie
pour ma famille côté on n'associe pas un
sac à des choses voilà on sait nous l'a
réussi un aussi essentiel et ensuite ce
qu'on a vu là sur les crocodiles je
trouve ça oui c'est vrai moi ça me
soulève le cap non mais ça fait quand
même ça fait quand même bruit que je
trouve dans les joues dumont bien sûr ma
vie que j'avais le sang chaud quand on
me demande si je suis choqué ou pas
choquer je suis choquée à la zone parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont été
choquées aussi apprennent on la connaît
donc forcément on sait comment elle
ravit nabila je pense qu'elle était
allée elle est pas dans ces
considérations
j'ai été choqué par le pas le fait que
les gens caste au mans les ans qu'il
avait pas les moyens qui vit aux
crochets des villages c'est vraiment
dégueulasse il gagne très bien sa vie
lui aussi en faisant des postes qu'il
faut voir et et me taper dessus en
revanche je suis choquée parce qu'en
fait c'est plus la vérité entre le les
postes promotionnelle commerciaux à la
est leur vraie vie ça je suis sûr qu'ils
ont une réduc sages n'ont censuré du son
et une réduction sur le prix du sag
hamas qui à présent faisait la promotion
sur des photos bien bien léché sur une
plage je sais alors qu'elle et ça me
choque ça tu sais que tu peux facilement
vérifier pour les postes qui sont
rémunérés ou pas où ils allaient de
réduction pas parce qu'il ya une loi
pour ça quand tu travailles sur les
réseaux sociaux et que c'est un
partenariat fille de m hashtag partant à
hashtag sponsorisé alors là c'est pas
porte l'arrière de classe bah non c'est
bien la famille c'est parfois crash au
québec et non tu fais pas un très bon
jeu mais on s'en fout l'ado d'histoire
pas choquer ni non moi je suis pas
choqué pour le prix du sac parce qu'elle
sait exactement ce qu'elle veut de son
argent
et comme disait valéry à la petite de
montrer toute sa vie donc ça veut
montrer ça c'est un petit peu sa ligne
de conduite donc un garde sa ligne de
conduite
mais par contre je suis choqué pour la
cause animale parce que c'est vrai que
là on voit les vidéos que les sites des
montres mais je suis sûr que nabila qui
va voir la vidéo
y a pas dit si c'était pas moi